was mr depp a difficult client to
represent
he wasn't initially and it became far
more complicated
in the last 10 years
of my representing him
and how did it become far more
complicated in the last 10 years you
represented him
[Music]
um
is unprofessional behavior
anything else
i think that covers a multitude of
things
and that's going to be my next question
what do you mean by mr depp's
unconfessional behavior
in the last 10 years of your legislation
showing up late to set
consistently
on virtually every movie
i would get yelled at i never said to
him you're a difficult client i never
use those words but i was very honest
with him and said you've got to stop
doing this this is hurting you
and it did
and
um
did
even with your speaking to mr deb about
him consistently showing up late for set
did he correct that behavior during that
last 10 years
now
and what types of difficulties
did that cause for
mr depp
well initially cruz loved him because he
was always so great with the crew but
crews don't love sitting around for
hours and hours and hours waiting for
the star of the movie to show up
and
it also got around town i mean people
talk it's a small community
and it made people
reluctant to use him toward the end
and
when you say toward the end was that
toward the end of your representation
of mr james
yes
are you aware of any significant role
that mr depp has starred in
since
you were terminated that you did not
negotiate and get it for him
now
did mr dick get the invisible man
they didn't make it they made it much
lower budget with the woman as it turns
out
for universal with lum house
you were asked about whether there was
any option contract for pirate sex
uh and i just want to make sure i
understand your answer did you were you
involved in any kind of negotiation with
disney for any kind of option contract
from pirate sex
with mr deb
not that i can recall
no